today more than half of the world's
population lives in cities the
realization process started in the late
seventeen hundreds and has been
increasing since then the prediction is
about 2050 66 percent of the population
will live in cities and the United
Nations the World Health Organization
the World Economic Forum are warning us
if we don't plan for increased density
current brands in our series like
inequality congestion crime can only get
worse as a result urban planners and
city developers are putting a lot of
effort and creativity in designing our
future vencer bigger cities but I have a
different opinion I think organization
is actually which in the end of a cycle
and now people are going to stop moving
back to the countryside and you may
think but what about the trend well let
me tell you so she can make trends don't
last forever
you know 12,000 years ago everybody was
perfectly happy roaming the land hunting
and gathering and then veteran changes
and the new thing is to live in a farm
and have cattle until it changes again
when we get to the Industrial Revolution
actually that is what started the
renovation process and you know what
triggered it steam power machines new
chemical processes in towards
technological innovation and I believe
technology can also bring the end of
this cycle having working on innovation
for most of my career I love it I love
my job it allows me to work with domes
with 3d printers and smart glasses and
not just those you can buy in the shop
but also prototypes it's a lot of fun
sometimes now some of these technologies
are opening new possibilities that will
radically change their way with these
things before and in a few years they
may allow us to enjoy the benefits of
city life from anywhere think about it
if you could live in place with a lower
crime rate and more space and a lower
cost of living and less traffic of
course many people want that but they
feel they don't have a choice
you have to live in the city well in the
past people moved to the cities not
because they loved the sale itself but
for the things you can have in a city
more your opportunities easier access to
services and goods and they reach such a
life so let's dive deeper more jobs and
career opportunities is a still true
today because the office people are
starting to realize that working in the
office and bein in the office mainly the
same thing anymore according to study by
global workplace analytics more than 80%
of the US workforce
we would like to work from home and do
you know how much it costs for a company
to even have an office eleven thousand
dollars per employee per year if only
half of the workers would telework even
50% time the savings in the States would
exceed five hundred billion dollars and
it will reduce greenhouse gases by 54
million tons that is the equivalent of
10 million cars of the streets for a
whole year
but even though most people would want
to telework current technology makes the
speeds isolating it's it's not
comfortable it doesn't feel like being
there that is going to change by the
convergence of two technologies
augmented reality and telepresence
robots our mental reality already today
allows you to take your office
environment everywhere with you all you
need is a world computer personal
glasses and you can take your emails and
your spreadsheets with you wherever you
go and video conferences and vehicles
have become very common these days but
just in need improvement like all those
little faces on a flat-screen sometimes
didn't even know who's talking now we
already have something way better than
static video calls your average
telepresence robot
I call it tablet on a stick you can
control you can move around you can
control what you're looking at it's way
better but far from perfect you know how
they say that most human communication
is nonverbal well the robot doesn't give
you any of that it looks like an alien
but with the advances in augmented
reality it will be easy to grab the
robot in a nice hologram that actually
looks and moves like a person then I'll
do it or else or else forget the robot
we go full VR and everybody meets in
cyberspace give it a couple of years and
that will feel so real you won't tell
the difference so what was the next
reason why people moved to cities access
to services and goods but today you can
do a lot online according to Steve Megan
by comScore online shoppers in the US
last year did more than half of the
retail purchases online and the global
market for e-commerce is estimated Lee
at 2 trillion dollars and is expected to
reach 2.38 by the end of 2017 according
to eMarketer
now from a logistic standpoint density
is good for deliveries supplying goods
to a so emo is easy you can send big
shipments to the shop and people will go
there pick it up and take it home
themselves ecommerce means we need two
sequences and have them home delivered
that's more expensive it's like the
difference between having a birthday
party for 20 people or bringing a piece
of the cake to each of your 20 friends
at their place
but at least in this city they live
close to each other
density helps now ecommerce deliveries
in the countryside those take forever
the Vic truck sometimes needs to drive
miles between one others in the next one
those are the most expensive the reviews
of all but we already have a solution
for that drones a vehicle carrying a
squadron of drones the driver does some
of the deliveries while the drones are
flying back and forth from the truck as
it moves that way the average cost for
the delivery is reduced and voila
affordable ecommerce services in the
countryside you will see the new homes
of our teleworkers will probably have a
drone pod in the yard so once the final
delivery is not a problem you don't need
to be in the city to buy things anymore
so that's true now what was the third
reason why people move to cities every
social life do we need to be in the city
for that these days because people these
days they make friends they chat gossip
in flirt from the comfort of their sofa
and while we're in the favorite pajamas
there are over two billion active social
media users in the world in a way that
makes you think like we are connected no
matter what we are but okay not
completely sometimes you still need some
real human contact ironically the city
which is population density it's not
always the same the best for that as
actually as people social groups become
smaller they grow stronger and a recent
study made in UK by the Office for
National Statistics showed a higher life
satisfaction rating among people living
in rural areas so as people settle in
the countryside well they will buy local
groceries fresh groceries food stuff
maintenance services so handymen small
workshops service companies will thrive
maybe some of the industrial workers
from the cities displaced by the
automation will find a nice alternative
yo here and they will move too and as
people moves to the countryside if how
is that going to be think about
autonomous of the grid houses with solar
panels with wind turbines and waste
recycling utilities our new homes
producing their own energy and using it
to also power the family car series have
always been regarded as being more
energy efficient but let me tell you
pretty popular in the countryside can be
equal to by now you're probably thinking
on the advantages of country living I
really myself six years ago my wife and
I we packed our stuff
we sold a little apartment in Spain and
for the same money with bought a house
with a garden and little birds that come
singing in the morning it's so nice
there and we live in a small village not
really can't decide yet that is going to
be - move the refurbish farmhouse
not too far from a city not too close
and now we'll be sure to have a good
spot for drones to land but hey that's
me it doesn't have to be because it will
seem like I'm trying to convince
somebody to come join us in the country
and not
I don't need more people to come I just
think they will once they realize they
can have the same benefits the city has
but if you don't like the country I have
good news for you two series will not
disappear but as people move south a
lower than city will help them recover a
better flow and balance anyway I guess
now you have some thinking to do
do you still think you need to live in
the city and more importantly that you
want to thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]